7 patients blood pressures
have been measured after
having been given a new
drug for 3 months.
They had blood pressure
increases of, and they give us
seven data points right here--
who knows, that's in some
blood pressure units.
Construct a 95% confidence
interval for the true expected
blood pressure increase for all
patients in a population.
So there's some population
distribution here.
It's a reasonable assumption
to think that it is normal.
It's a biological process.
So if you gave this drug to
every person who has ever
lived, that will result in some
mean increase in blood
pressure, or who knows, maybe
it actually will decrease.
And there's also going to be
some standard deviation here.
It is a normal distribution.
And the reason why it's
reasonable to assume that it's
a normal distribution
is because it's
a biological process.
It's going to be the sum of many
thousands and millions of
random events.
And things that are sums of
millions and thousands of
random events tend to be
normal distribution.
So this is a population
distribution.
And we don't know anything
really about it outside of the
sample that we have here.
Now, what we can do is, and this
tends to be a good thing
to do, when you do have a
sample just figure out
everything that you can
figure out about that
sample from the get-go.
So we have our seven
data points.
And you could add them up and
divide by 7 and get your
sample mean.
So our sample mean
here is 2.34.
And then you can also
calculate your
sample standard deviation.
Find the square distance from
each of these points to your
sample mean, add them up, divide
by n minus 1, because
it's a sample, then take the
square root, and you get your
sample standard deviation.
I did this ahead of time
just to save time.
Sample standard deviation
is 1.04.
And when you don't know anything
about the population
distribution, the thing that
we've been doing from the
get-go is estimating that
character with our sample
standard deviation.
So we've been estimating the
true standard deviation of the
population with our sample
standard deviation.
Now in this problem, this exact
problem, we're going to
run into a problem.
We're estimating our standard
deviation with an n of only 7.
So this is probably going to
be a not so good estimate
because-- let me just write--
because n is small.
In general, this is considered
a bad estimate if n
is less than 30.
Above 30 you're dealing
in the realm
of pretty good estimates.
So the whole focus of this video
is when we think about
the sampling distribution, which
is what we're going to
use to generate our interval,
instead of assuming that the
sampling distribution is normal
like we did in many
other videos using the central
limit theorem and all of that,
we're going to tweak the
sampling distribution.
We're not going to assume it's
a normal distribution because
this is a bad estimate.
We're going to assume that
it's something called a
t-distribution.
And a t-distribution is
essentially, the best way to
think about is it's almost
engineered so it gives a
better estimate of your
confidence intervals and all
of that when you do have
a small sample size.
It looks very similar to
a normal distribution.
It has some mean, so this is
your mean of your sampling
distribution still.
But it also has fatter tails.
And the way I think about why
it has fatter tails is when
you make an assumption that this
is a standard deviation
for-- let me take
one more step.
So normally what we do is we
find the estimate of the true
standard deviation, and then
we say that the standard
deviation of the sampling
distribution is equal to the
true standard deviation of our
population divided by the
square root of n.
In this case, n is equal to 7.
And then we say OK, we never
know the true standard, or we
seldom know-- sometimes you do
know-- we seldom know the true
standard deviation.
So if we don't know that the
best thing we can put in there
is our sample standard
deviation.
And this right here, this is the
whole reason why we don't
say that this is just a 95
probability interval.
This is the whole reason why
we call it a confidence
interval because we're making
some assumptions.
This thing is going to change
from sample to sample.
And in particular, this is going
to be a particularly bad
estimate when we have a
small sample size, a
size less than 30.
So when you are estimating the
standard deviation where you
don't know it, you're estimating
it with your sample
standard deviation, and your
sample size is small, and
you're going to use this to
estimate the standard
deviation of your sampling
distribution, you don't assume
your sampling distribution
is a normal distribution.
You assume it has
fatter tails.
And it has fatter tails because
you're essentially
underestimating-- you're
underestimating the standard
deviation over here.
Anyway, with all of that said,
let's just actually go through
this problem.
So we need to think about a 95%
confidence interval around
this mean right over here.
So a 95% confidence interval,
if this was a normal
distribution you would just
look it up in a Z-table.
But it's not, this is
a t-distribution.
We're looking for a 95%
confidence interval.
So some interval around
the mean that
encapsulates 95% of the area.
For a t-distribution you use
t-table, and I have a t-table
ahead of time right over here.
And what you want to do is use
the two-sided row for what
we're doing right over here.
And the best way to think
about it is that we're
symmetric around the mean.
And that's why they
call it two-sided.
It would be one-sided if it
was kind of a cumulative
percentage up to some
critical threshold.
But in this case, it's
two-sided, we're symmetric.
Or another way to think
about it is we're
excluding the two sides.
So we want the 95%
in the middle.
And this is a sampling
distribution of the sample
mean for n is equal to 7.
And I won't go into the details
here, but when n is
equal to 7 you have 6 degrees
of freedom, or n minus 1.
And the way that t-tables are
set up, you go and find the
degrees of freedom.
So you don't go to the n,
you go to the n minus 1.
So you go to the 6 right here.
So if you want to encapsulate
95% of this right over here,
and you have an n of 6, you
have to go 2.447 standard
deviations in each direction.
And this t-table assumes that
you are approximating that
standard deviation using your
sample standard deviation.
So another way to think of it
you have to go 2.447 of these
approximated standard
deviations.
Let me it right here.
So you have to go 2.447-- this
distance right here is 2.447
times this approximated
standard deviation.
And sometimes you'll see this
in some statistics book.
This thing right here,
this exact number,
is shown like this.
They put a little hat on top of
the standard deviation to
show that it has been
approximated using the sample
standard deviation.
So we'll put a little hat over
here, because frankly, this is
the only thing that
we can calculate.
So this is how far you have
to go in each direction.
And we know what
this value is.
We know what the sample
distribution is.
So let's get our
calculator out.
So we know our sample standard
deviation is 1.04.
And we want to divide that
by the square root of 7.
So we get 0.39.
So this right here is 0.39.
And so if we want to find
the distance around this
population mean that
encapsulates 95% of the
population or of the sampling
distribution, we have to
multiply 0.39 times 2.447,
so let's do that.
So times 2.447 is
equal to 0.96.
So this is equal to-- so this
distance right here is 0.96,
and then this distance
right here is 0.96.
So if you take a random sample,
and that's exactly
what we did when we found
these 7 samples.
When we took these 7 samples and
took their mean, that mean
can be viewed as a random
sample from the sampling
distribution.
And so the probability, and so
we can view it, we could say
that there's a 95% chance-- and
we have to actually caveat
everything with a confident,
because we're doing all of
these estimations here.
So it's not a true precise
95% chance.
We're just confident that
there's a 95% chance that our
random population, our random
sampling mean right here, so
that 2.34, which we can kind of
use-- we just picked that
2.34 from this distribution
right here.
So there's a 95% chance that
2.34 is within 0.96 of the
true sampling distribution mean,
which we know is also
the same thing as the
population mean.
Or we can just rearrange the
sentence and say that there is
a 95% chance that the mean, the
true mean, which is the
same thing as a sampling
distribution mean, is within
0.96 of our sample
mean, of 2.34.
So at the low end, so if you go
2.36 minus-- if you go 2.34
minus 0.96-- that's the low
end of our confidence
interval, 1.38.
And the high end of our
confidence interval, 2.34 plus
0.96 is equal to 3.3.
So our 95% confidence interval
is from 1.38 to 3.3.